hi guys itself arete again and today I'm
going to do some supports and the game
is kinda lagging right now but the thing
is basically last time everyone said
then I was complaining too much about
how my station really sucked so I'm kind
of sorry for doing that okay my station
is beautiful
it's um oh I'm crying nearly crying no
basically I don't really like this
station that much but I know it's a
tutorial and I know that many of you
have commented that you actually liked
it so I guess that as long as people
really liked it and it's not that bad
after all that it's okay and it can stay
and I might add a little like some
details some places for example the
dormers need some fixing and i need some
extra windows and extra details but I'll
do that sauce later on because people
have been waiting for me to do the
supports and so that's what I'm going to
do right now now right so I'm the first
thing that I would usually do is take
Costa Jose B and M connectors and this
is a set that you really need if you
want to make them especially and well of
course only for B&M coasters except for
those intamin coasters and joven Ola
coasters that use the same track but
basically for if you're confused about
the situation right here for any coaster
type that uses this kind of track this
is the this is the support set that
you're going to want to use since as you
can see it perfectly connects to the
bottom of the track which is because
it's a B and I'm well it's a be an M
connector set and I don't see everyone
using these things but I would recommend
you to use these things because um these
are the things that you use to connect
the track with the supports and I think
I just called them Trek connectors but
they're called support connectors but in
any case that's not too important so
what I generally do is I place these
Trek connectors on every well square one
where I want to have a support later on
now for a lift hill in the beginning I
usually take about three and a half to
three squares maybe even four or five
squares but like as the
learn the distance between these
connectors so I'm at three and a half
right here so three and a half from that
point should be right here and so on but
I did kind of notice that the close the
closer the coaster is to the ground
there's a slightly smaller difference in
the distance between the connectors so
usually at the top of the lift Hill I
take like distance of four
simply because it looks better though in
this case I'm probably not going to do
that because this coaster is very small
and it would kind of look weird if on
such a small lift sail I would use
different distances right so this should
all line up and it does so because this
one is on the line right here it should
be in the middle of the square right
here and instead of using a gentle or
Steve one it seems like I'm going to
have to use a gentle to steep one right
here and I've seen a lot of people have
difficulties with this set because it
uses particular connectors for every
single piece of track that you have in
the game for example this is a gentle to
steep track and that's of course a
gentle decision okay that's of course a
gentle too steep connector in this um
set so well this is the easier thing but
for example there are also cobras and
loopings that you want to support and
you will need to get some specific
connectors for every specific tile so
that's something that kind of makes
working with a set a bit hard but it
does make it very versatile so that's
very handy so for big drops like these
where you have this very smooth gradual
steep drop I would usually use a gentle
to steep paired with a flat one on the
bottom like this
now it should kind of that it should
kind of match but you can also use a
flatter gentle because it's just a
little bit higher now for the Cobra roll
right here the way I usually support
these is I take a half loop support
right here and I take two corkscrew
supports for the corkscrews now I assume
many people actually just place one
support in the middle right here but
this is not very realistic it probably
can yeah I don't think it really can
take the weight of the corkscrew yeah
and they're like there I go again saying
that young again like people post the
comments about that as well well I'm
screw it
yeah as a beautiful word I can abuse any
beautiful word nobody's going to stop me
I'm an independent black woman oh yeah
okay right now for those of you
wondering why I'm kind of some kind of
awkward speaking to myself right now I'm
in a skype going people are listening to
me and they're laughing their asses off
and being annoyingly old brats and
that's because they they want you to
record this in a Skype call with them in
the Skype call to laugh at me
commentating yes so basically that's
that right so I'm just going to ignore
them and yeah continue with this yeah
and you can see them already lost in the
set because I'm trying to find the half
loop piece and okay this is not working
out okay um right so now these
connectors actually have two pieces and
you're going to have you're going to
want to change the color of the top
piece to the color of the track and the
color of the bottom piece to the color
of the supports and like I did with all
the supports on the lift Hill you've got
a top piece for that and you've got a
bottom piece for that as well and the
same counts for that you're going to and
what you're going to want a top piece do
you have the same color as the track and
the bottom piece that's the same color
as the supports
right so now for these large corkscrews
I'm going to choose whichever corkscrew
and whichever direction they're heading
now this one seems to be a left one so I
want to have to build a left connector
right here which is kind of hard
matching to the height of the track but
it's no it's not too much of a big job
right so you have to do the same thing
on this side and that's about mmm I
think one third of the right connected
already and usually the way I do this is
just to make this job no too boring is I
kind of cut the layouts in pieces where
I think like okay I'm going to do one
third of the right I'm going to connect
one third of the right using these
connectors and then I'm going to build
the rest of the supports and then use
connectors on the other part of the
right so that's what I'm going to do
right now as well just to make sure that
it all looks nice and it's yeah it just
all fits so I'm just going to build the
supports for this part already just
going to connect this with a vertical
one and it seems like that's quite a big
gap right here so I'm going to have to
use a medium connector on that's in a
little bit
all right so now this is probably not
even know this is not a good idea the
way I usually do this because that's how
PNM to work in real life is being a mess
actually
the lift Hills consist of mostly either
12 H or 8 H or well H 8 or H 12 bars
depending on how high they are basically
now they usually don't have any vertical
beam so what I just did you can do that
if you pair it with a H beam for example
but I don't like doing that I prefer
using this kind of method and as you can
see it looks kind of white now because
it's about three it's about three
squares wide for a about 12 squares high
piece of track so I don't really like
the look of that so I'm going to use a H
12 for this one and you don't need to
worry about whether it actually yeah but
whether it actually fits on the ground
and whether you can actually place a
footer down right here because I'm going
to talk about the photos later on but
you don't have to worry about that at
this point because there's a being and
footer set that has placement for about
every single place of a roller coaster
tycoon 3 tile right so now I'm the top
of the lift Hill of a bnm those kind of
a weird thing where it uses diagonal
beams that kind of point towards each
other in this kind of way so this is
what I always like to do and it looks
kind of cool it makes the lift Hill look
a little bit less boring and it makes it
look more sturdy as well because um
basically you've got the forces of the
roller coaster directed like going in
this direction on this side and then it
needs to support the track to the other
side on the other side of course so you
kind of get that circle going on so it
kind of looks like supporting a hill
like that it's just uh it's just a I
don't know it's a physics thing and I
suck at physics um
right so now for this part of the right
we can actually use some vertical on
some vertical beams because um yeah for
for the less high place
is in a rollercoaster it's pretty common
for bunam coasters to just have vertical
beams except for the for when it's for
example a dive machine but might cover
that later on but for now just forget
about that and you can just use some
vertical beams right here now these
looping parts I think have some weird
alignments yeah they're on the edge
living on the edge well so you gotta use
these edge parts for this and an edge
part in mobile steel jungle means that
you cannot connect any angled arm beam
to it so I'm going to have to use some
either h4 or h8 beams just because
simply I can't connect the diagonal
beams to this so I feel like yeah 4-h
looks kind of decent now for the
corkscrews if you want to use a vertical
beam a center beam it looks like Center
beam by the way if you're in doubt about
the placement of a connector just go to
a vertical view and look where it lines
up and and I can see that it's in this
square and that it's a center beam and
as you can see that is really really
close to the track well kind of yeah it
does go through the track so that's not
very healthy if your guests are going to
write this Oh probably going to die and
you don't want that so um in this
situation I normally take either an 8 H
or a 4 H beam on the side and in this
case because it's a very small it's a
very small Cobra loop so I think a 4h
shouldn't do the job but I'm not
entirely sure now it does look kind of
weird so I might try something else okay
I'm getting this to line up is a bit
hard again oh wait damn it
doesn't seem like this thing wants to
work let's see okay yeah I got it right
so now yeah this looks too wide I'm
going to have to try some some 8h though
I'm not sure about that either and I
wish that at this point that was a 6h
but that's not the situation right here
we need to use either four eight zero
six or an HP 8h so in case of a doubt
and you want to use a 6h but you can't
do that
then what I would normally do is use a
four H on one side on the side where it
doesn't cross the track and use an eight
H on the other side where it doesn't
cross the track anyway so I'm going to
do the same thing right here as soon as
I get this wing lined up I'm going to
use a 4h snap extend it to get it over
there and then on the other side use an
8 H
right so now that looks pretty decent
although it does look kind of wide and
weird but in any case I'm going to
continue on using the same thing on the
other side so 4-h on one side and 8h on
the other side right so that's the Cobra
loop which does look nicer from some
directions and from other ones but in
any case it's supported well enough to
carry in some weight so now we're on to
the looping and looping doing a doing a
looping is actually really hard in this
game since ice yeah I didn't really find
any set yet that actually had great
pieces to do this with I mean there is
of course the connector set but the
connector set doesn't really have great
looping pieces and yeah I can I can show
that right now
right so ICT ICT just crashed and you
didn't notice of course because I kind
of skipped that I couldn't record that
but I had to redo everything so I had to
redo this point as well so I really hope
that I did them exactly in the way then
I had them before and I'm going to very
quickly just finish up this episode
right here and I'm going to finish it we
are well I just have to finish these
supports and do the looping supports so
like I did before just going to do the
edge supports real quick here and then
that should be done also I added this
little um support at the bottom right
here so that it's symmetrical right but
moving on to the looping there's there
is a connector piece for the looping of
course but I don't really like it too
much it doesn't look that sturdy but
it's good enough and it's quite
realistic enough as realistic as one
might possibly get it in this game so
you want to take the where is it small
loop something the small loop left right
and then you're gonna want to wait oh
well that's great the lipping goes the
left but you have to take the thing
right okay you might remember that it
depends of no it doesn't even depend on
well yeah it does depend yeah okay it's
right from the direction where the
coaster comes from so anyway you want to
place these where they align that is
which is quite low it's in that it's in
the exactly well it's probably still in
the lower half of the loop actually
right there which is also a edge
placement if I'm not mistaken yeah it is
an edge placement and this is exactly
the one problem that I have with this
placement because so far it actually
looks good enough once I but um the
thing is that mobi steel jungle does
have edge placements like this which you
can line with these
but it does not have a straight edge
connecting kind of sports and what I
mean with that is it's really hard to
actually add a nice support over here
because you can't take the diagonal ones
because those don't really match up with
the edgy ones
achee huh that's that came out wrong the
edge ones basically and the regular ones
they're not on the grid like that either
so you're going to have to take a 4h
four edge and connect it like this which
is kind of awkward if you ask me so this
is one possibility that you can go for
and this looks quite okay from the sides
but if you're going to take like a front
cam it looks like this which is kind of
weird which is why I don't like this and
there's no real other possibility other
than I'm just going to quickly sketch
this for those who want to see this
placing a supports I think it's right
here placing it supports either here or
here and then taking a small diagonal
quarter piece and using that to connect
it to the track and then you can
actually do anything anything with this
but the way the reason why I don't like
that is because then the sport will have
a really weird placement and you also
don't use the B and M connectors that
are a lot more realistic than using
mobile steel jungle as a connector but
yeah this that'll be it for today
because I'm on about almost 18 minutes
once I'm done with this and I'm sorry
for not being too productive I try to be
a little bit more productive but I do
want to tell everything of every part of
the process of making the coaster and
not that does include the support which
can sometimes be horrendous especially
at this point where my game has crashed
and I had to redo them so sorry for all
that but next time I'm going to try to
nearly finish this I hope that I can
actually finish it because this is not
too much work generally the lower the
track is the easier it is to add some
support because if it's it's if it's
really low in line
you don't really need to add anything
like side beams across beams to really
support it so that's that for today and
I'm hoping to see you in the next
episode
you